Let's finish the job of decoupling the car class from the use of System.out.
There's a second print statement in the drive method where we print something
out every time that a passenger gets dropped off. So we want to move this again
to the simulation class that caused the drive method. There's just one problem
and that is that this statement occurs in a loop. There may be more than one
printout per call to drive. So let's think a bit out of the box here. We drive
the car to the next location and what could we tell the caller? We could tell
the caller what the passengers are that have been dropped off. So go ahead,
take this out. Change the return type so that it now returns an array list of
person each time you remove a passenger, stick it into that array list. And at
the end of the method, return that array list. In the drivesCars method of the
stimulation class, look at where you called drive. Now that returns a value
namely an array list of person. Save that array list in a variable. Then make a
loop over all of the people in that list and for each of them, print the drop
off message. Go ahead and implement that now.